(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] (whispering) Zucchini.
(screams)
(laughing)
- Got you!
- How did you come up with that?
- I don't know, I just saw
the tube I knew what to do.
- What's so funny guys, zucchini?
- You had to be there man, yeah.
- Classic me.
- I am there.
- I will never get tired of this bit.
(laughing)
- Tube, tube, tube, tube, tube, tube.
- [All] Tube, tube, tube!
- Hey, Gaelin, what's up, what's up?
Hey, you think I'm funny right?
- Oh yeah, I mean you're
not Snapple cap funny,
but I do laugh at you a lot.
- Oh, thanks.
(whispering) Tube.
- Jesus Elliott, what the hell?
- What, nothing, it's
just the joke, right?
- Tube? That's disgusting.
- Yeah Elliott, that's not cool.
Whispering tube, that's like sexual.
- No, no, it's not a sex
word, just like zucchini.
- Elliott, zucchinis are
funny, like eggplants.
- Or cucumbers.
- Or rhubarb.
- But those are all things
you can like stick into...
- [All] Oh! Come on man!
- Rhubarb?
- Okay fine, look her I can fix this.
It was just a joke.
Here, I can fix this.
What did the rabbi say to the magician?
- Elliott...
- Come on.
- I'm pretty sure Charlie is Jewish.
Or Peruvian or something.
- Jeruvian.
I thought more of you.
- I know, I love Jewish things.
Look, let me try again.
Okay, knock knock.
- Who's there?
- Penis.
- [All] What? Whoa!
- Come on, that's the thing.
- Okay fine, here.
Here, zucchini.
- Killed the joke.
(upbeat music)
- Squash.
- [Voiceover] You got it back, you did it!
- Dude, dude, dude, dude!